j'avais peur qu'on me regarde comme un
bon tout ça mais on n'a peut-être pas
mon handicap
il ya eu des gens qui m'ont dit tu es en
du cab et doit pas être comédien à
chaque fois je demandais à chaque prise
est scotché miller
[Musique]
au monticule peut-être une partie
seulement le fait des gestes bizarres
les gens ont peur ça voilà
mais quand je suis certaine là je suis
quelqu'un d'autre je pense que faire
quand j'ai fais tu tiennes en amateur en
étant tout jeune c'était un peu comme un
médicament un remède quelque chose qui
nous dirait qui me fait sentir bien
c'est pour ça que je souhaitais devenir
professionnel il faut continuer ce
combat et guéret il est clair que dans
la vie quotidienne
je ne fais n'importe quel handicap c'est
pas vraiment adapté mais par contre si
ie mais par contre si on s'habitue à
faire avec à vivre avec et l'utiliser
comme comme un outil pour aller plus
loin là ça devient une force est là
là on voit que on peut vraiment aller
plus loin que ce que les autres pensent
c'est comme vous savez il ya des
personnes qui bégaye
et à partir du moment où elle chante
elle perdre ce bégaiement et c'est ça ou
on s'est rendu compte avec avec ses deux
ces deux zigotos là qu'ils pouvaient
transmettre m'étais vraiment des
émotions et je vous le dis dans le film
ils sont incroyables en fait les deux
jouent tellement vrai tellement simple
et tellement on se prend en pleine
gueule
ils demandent rien d'autre que d'être
pris comme des personnes normales et de
vivre une vie normale
soyons clairs personne n'est normal
c'est vrai
et s et puis voilà c'est juste que moi
je suis autistes l'opa sartrouville axel
se trouve il a d'autres problèmes
moi je n'ai pas mais que lui il a
entendu john est tous des jeunes sous
mac sans nom et les êtres vivants
on est tous des êtres humains le bon
dieu nous ça a été comme ça et c'est
vrai que ceux qui se mordent tous seuls
comme s'ils n'ont pas été gentil avec
moi et où clément ou les autres il
comprenait rien le plus gros problème de
ce qu'il ya de ski de ce qui entoure le
monde des personnes en situation de
handicap
c'est le regard des autres qui par
moment est très restreint il faut se
battre on prend ses rêves et ceux qui
diraient pairs du continent
les échos des baby vaudrait à fond si
c'est pour devenir un comédien chanteur
danseur professionnel ou je sais pas
quoi présentatrice météo rien vous rêvez
pas c'est vous